though often you filthy little unrefined
Viking kindly stopped chewing on the
subscribe button for the new world
review take it out of your mouth impress
it like a normal human being which wrote
results in regular anime and content
uploaded straight until YouTube feed
hello and welcome to the new old Evo
Souls for everything anime and manga and
today it's time for a long long overdue
video regarding my thoughts on season 1
of villain saga which concluded its run
an awfully long time ago now but I'm
only just now getting on top of it and
it's a bit of a weird situation actually
because I did my first impression of the
series bobbed it and then I kind of
forgot it was airing when other things
took priority so on the bright side I
had a very solid amount of episodes to
just watch one after the other and it
reminded me why I love this series so
much to begin with oh and in case it
isn't obvious this video will contain
spoilers for the villain saga anime and
haven't read the manga so no fears there
or I should say I haven't read the manga
yet because I'm highly tempted to give
it a go given the pretty damn incredible
note that the anime left us on but
really in retrospect Finland saga was
such a solid series for a pseudo history
and I say that because I don't generally
go for that kind of genre if we're doing
this sort of thing I would prefer solid
fantasy or just an incarnation of the
world that is far removed from our own
but really I might have to revisit that
whole idea because just as how haikyuu
got me excited to explore some more
sports related series Finland saga has
shown me that yes I have probably been
sleeping on pseudo historical --zz and I
won't repeat everything I said in the
first impressions video but to delve
properly into this one one of the most
stunning things about Finland saga is
simply characters and they only get
stronger and stronger the further I
traveled with them we begin in a fairly
simple place with figures like Thor's
who st. Maul most legendary in
retrospect because every time he was
featured in a little flashback in the
latter half of the series it just made
me feel like wow it's been an awfully
long while since we've seen him and
almost like he'd slipped into the realm
of mythology
oh I don't know how much that is just me
having a giant gap between starting and
finishing the series but I think this
thought is especially potent since we
have yet to meet any other character who
is equatable for Thor's in any way he
just had it all strengths philosophy
love whatever it was this man held it
maybe not a man but something of a God
amongst men and in this turbulent
hellhole he had it figured out whereas
it seems like every other character
struggles in this world including
prolific figures like a squad who's
speaking of is without a doubt my
favorite character in the series thus
far and his death in episode 24 well
that was quite the rough experience for
me
rough
conflicting I should say because as much
as I liked us glad the reality of his
existence was never really lost on me he
could be an exceptionally cruel being
but also oddly selectively kind but most
importantly at all times he was
charismatic plus he also became much
easier to empathize with after his whole
past was revealed which he know is
rather predictably tragic as is the past
and it would seem fate of every
character in Vinland saga but the degree
to which high school I was humanized for
me is kind of insane I think I was very
much on his wavelength and able to
identify with him far more than anybody
else and really ask aloud forms to call
emotional structure of this season and
what I mean by that is very simple stuff
like when asked if I was angry I was
angry when he felt betrayed I felt
betrayed and when he sliced off the head
of that our Suckley king I was both
shocked and thrilled
mostly thrilled because there was a
great sense of satisfaction in seeing us
collide not back down even if he knew
that it was going to bring about heavily
unfavorable consequences but contrast
that to someone like Thor Finn for
example I really like Thor Fenn but he
became increasingly more difficult for
me to empathize with there were just so
many points where he took the concept of
raw fury to a whole new level and I
actually found myself very much siding
with Oscar Ladd in these situations just
being like oh come on come down kid it's
not really that bad even though it kind
of is well though of course just like
leave I am very much unable to
understand the pain that Thor Finn
perpetually exists in well that's not
entirely true I do understand it
theoretically but as a viewer it gets a
bit exhausting at times not many times
though I think that often has a generous
but not excessive amount to focus
essentially being partner form or
ensemble cast rather than being the
protagonist of the story
at least in this part anyway because
without Scott out of the way Thor think
would very much retake that mantle I
guess there's also Knut and speaking of
how canoe it was probably one of the
greatest surprises that this series had
to offer when he was first introduced I
did have an inkling that he was being
set up for some kind of rapid growth as
a character because someone if his how
shall we say crippling emotional
fragility has absolutely no chance of
surviving in a world like this however
what I did not expect at all was for
Knut to become even an iota as awesome
as he did so much so that I'm honestly a
bit conflicted about that moment of
transformation because it really did
seem like a switch got flicked in
cahoots mind and then all of a sudden
that set him on the path of becoming a
real leader and I get that he did have
that whole epiphany moment of
discovering what love is with priests
but still to go from what he was to a
man who seems to inspire
and acquire those around him in
effectively no time at all is pretty
wild wild but very welcome there because
I was expecting this whole Knut business
to be a long long slog of a character
out in my mind by at the end of season
one I would have guessed that we'd have
made our first step of progress with
guna doing something minor like speaking
up or committing some sort of small
action of consequence that his character
would then go on to snowball from then
but no we skipped all of that process
and all of a sudden Knut is a boss and
sure why not and while were in the Knut
region I said in my first impressions of
this series that I wasn't sold very much
on the character of Ragnar I mean by and
large I do really enjoy the fact that
villain saga what's a realistic take on
character design but I initially just
found his wide breadth and Coen head
fairly visually off-putting as well as
his generally prudish and all too
honorable attitude however I do
definitely rescind those thoughts though
because he turned out to be quite an
unexpected source of heart and his death
was genuinely painful to watch one of
those characters who I really did not
know how much actually enjoyed until he
was gone and I could talk for hours
about characters even the minor one else
get some pretty meaty development but
there is just so much more to this
series than that so we do need to move
on and I don't remember what I said
about this in my other video or even if
I spoke about it at all but the
animation of Vinland saga is pretty damn
pristine and very much on full display
during any number of great action
sequences anytime Thornton left into the
fray I knew we were in for something of
a visual feast and I loved the way his
clashes against thorkil were handled in
particular there was some really Schmitt
camerawork with some super Swift yet
exceptionally hard hit in combat which
also owes a great deal to marvelous
editing music and sound design
everything just comes together and works
so well there is no weak link in any
department of villain saga which is very
interesting because I actually don't
think it particularly excels in any
given area either if you isolate the
animation the sound or whatever they
would probably be pretty average out of
context but this just goes to show the
kind of products that exceptional
competence in all areas can produce
every department just bands together to
become some sort of super being like I
would never call Vinland saga the best
animated series or say that it has the
best music or even say that it has the
greatest story or even characters but it
most certainly does possess each of
these elements at an above-average level
which makes it nothing short of
infinitely compelling briefly on music
though because it did mention it my
favorite auditory hit to come out of
inland saga was the very first opening
which was Macondo by survives at the
profit in
fact I went and downloaded it
immediately after hearing it for the
first time which I want to emphasize is
incredibly rare for me I usually take
quite a bit of time to warm up to
opening music but I feel like the song
wonderfully encapsulates everything that
the sport has to offer
it has moments of deep beauty epic
energy and really gritty vocals that
make you think that you've truly stepped
into this time and feel like part of
this world and so it did a really great
job of priming me for the episode to
follow I was a lot less sold on the
second opening which is dark crow by man
with a mission and it's primarily
because I just don't feel like it has
the depth of feel that the first opening
had it was much more of a generic
Japanese rock piece which is not to say
that it didn't grow on me by the end of
the series I did love it especially the
section where you get the close-ups of
Ascalon Knut and often as well as the
whole chorus where you see Thor Kozak
swinging it was pretty good stuff but it
never managed to get me quite as hyped
as Makarova and as for the endings
neither of these are songs that
particularly appeal to me because I tend
to go for very high-energy music however
I will say that both of them were very
welcome reprieves at the end of an
episode because every part of Vinland
saga felt long and intense so to reach
the end of an episode and be greeted
with such blissful and peaceful music
served as a pretty effective chaser as
well as a reminder that no matter how
bad things get there is always hope or
you know something super wanky like that
basically it was good music to take a
moment to exhale and then move on and
really I hold pretty high praise for how
the content of each episode was handled
getting to the end of an episode always
felt like a monumental experience to me
and I can't tell you the amount of times
I reached the halfway point and you get
a little Vinland saga card and I just
thought to myself oh my god there's more
because the first half of these episodes
could fill an entire episodes worth of
content in any lesser series so it
really did feel like there was a supreme
amount of value in watching villain saga
and the episodes felt so very long but
in the best possible way even the ones
that had a very quiet focus in fact
especially the ones where things kind of
came to a halt and we had the
opportunity to really zoom in on
something
ocelots flashback would be a good
example of an episode like this but also
the one where they slaughter a whole
village to hole up for the winter that
episode was extremely slow but then
again that was the appropriate pacing
the content demanded that we really hit
the brakes at times and I can imagine
that that might actually noise some
people who just want to keep pumping
forward but I really liked the variants
of pace and I don't think there was
every time where I felt oh this is
moving too slowly or even the opposite
with
weh-weh we are going way too fast I mean
well with the exception of Knut sudden
character shift but as for the end of
the series itself one of the main
reasons why I'm considering moving to
the manga is simply because of the title
of the final episode which is the end of
the prologue which is one of the most
brilliant yet frustrating titles I've
ever encountered in all of media because
it gives you this feeling of wait this
wasn't even the main meat of the story
you mean to tell me that this was all
set up for something bigger then after
my interest is piqued the reality that
there are no more episodes swiftly sets
in and it's just like so I guess you
could say the villain saga well and
truly did its job as an anime adaptation
because it has motivated me to pick up
the manga and continue the story
although the one thing I will say it
didn't really get as the montage at the
end of episode 24 which I'm assuming is
a hint of things to come like a brief
little highlight of characters from
future arcs or whatever and just to give
the manga fans a little
something-something to watch and go hey
I know that guy as well as to tease
anime Watchers like me with a my you
style feeling whatever the case it
worked
everything about Finland saga worked it
is an undeniable triumph of 2019 and the
series that I am incredibly glad that I
took the time to watch eventually that
is but I pretty much does it for my
final thoughts on season 1 of Finland
saga but what do you guys think please
do leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server if
you like to see more Finland saga videos
or any other anime mark content then
please do subscribe to the channel which
effectively acts as a kick in the butt
letting me know your desires but for now
this has been the New World review and
I'll see you next time